[Music]
it looks like a car and it drives like a
tricycle a child-sized version of a
motorized three-wheeler vehicle popular
in the early 20th century instead of gas
pedal power propels this replica forward
based on actual vehicles a wave of
nostalgia has put pedal cars on the road
to a comeback
[Music]
an old style pedal car is a snazzy toy
with a sleek metal body and real rubber
tires
highly collectible owning one is a trip
down memory lane
production starts with the pedal cars
wood floor the worker places a metal
template of the floor under a sheet of
ash plywood and transfers the two to a
router table
with a pin in the template below to
guide him he moves the plywood as the
router cuts it
this produces a part that's the precise
size and shape needed for the pedal car
floor
[Music]
using the same system he cuts a slot for
the pedals and another one for the rear
wheel
he evens the edges with the hand router
giving the pedal car floor a finer look
and feel
[Music]
he glues supports for the backrest close
to the rear of the floorboard
he props the backrest against the
supports and screws it into
position he installs the dashboard
framework further towards the front
next they varnish the laminated ash
dashboard a deep rich hue to replicate
the look of the one in the original
three wheeler vehicle
and now for the body of the pedal car
a welder tacks together the two parts of
the aluminum shell and seals them with
special adhesive
they then screw the wooden framework to
the aluminum body after a thorough
cleaning they paint a primer coat onto
the metal
then it's into the paint booth for a
glossy coat of automotive paint
in the meantime the metal chassis of the
pedal car comes together
a worker mounts a dummy twin engine to
the front
in this pedal-powered replica the
engine's purpose is purely decorative
the headlights though are real he
attaches those to the chassis
complete with a hooded framework
distinctive to the original full-sized
three-wheeled car from a century ago
[Music]
he then fits the tires to the chassis
they're cycle tires child sized to fit
the scale of this toy car replica a
quick spin confirms they're operational
he mounts the fenders to the frame just
above the tires and secures them with
metal brackets
the fenders will guard against splashing
mud and
water he now transfers the car body to
the three-wheeled chassis he aligns it
with fixing points on the chassis and
then screws it into place
next he hooks up the exhaust pipe
like the engine it's an imitation but it
looks real
he fits an aluminum grille to the front
of the pedal car just behind the mock
engine
he installs a small windshield in front
of the pedal car cockpit
and now he pops the dashboard equipped
with the speed dial into place it fits
into the pedal car's hooped frame
perfectly
he wires the battery-operated headlights
to the dashboard switch
he attaches the handbrake to the side of
the cab and runs the braking cables to
the rear wheel
[Music]
he threads the steering wheel column
down through the dashboard to steering
arms on the front wheel axle
he clamps it to the steering arms
and make some adjustments to precisely
position the column to the shaft
[Music]
he fits the padded leather seat into the
cab and this completes the construction
of this pedal-powered replica car
it takes about 40 hours to make one of
these retro toys
when it comes to the authentic touches
they've spared no expense and expended
great effort
it's time for a spin to the playground
and some good old-fashioned fun
[Music]
you